[Music]
you have such a successful career going
right now with not only your run on
stranger things and everyone loving barb
how does it feel to be nominated tonight
for that particular role it's incredible
I mean I never would have imagined this
in a million years so just being here
it's a little overwhelming but I'm so so
happy so thankful it was your initial
reaction when you found out that you
were nominated with how your character
ended on the show I was gonna just in
shock I remember like just sort of
sitting there like shaking I was at the
airport at the time actually and this
woman walked by with a therapy dog and
I'm like and I please pet your dog I'm
like having a panic attack and it was
great and I typed the dog and I felt
better I mean what your career has just
like skyrocketed since then so many fans
Riverdale coming up and I mean I'm
really excited for that season ruining
our lives and to them it's just a game
is that your character really gonna
evolve this season I think so yeah I
think we're really going to see Ethel
sort of come into her own which I'm very
excited about lots of twists and turns
definitely the the mystery is not over
but it's going to be very exciting seems
like your character was sort of a good
girl in the beginning but some
circumstances have changed are we gonna
see that good girl go bad now I don't
quite know yet actually it's still kind
of a process
you